المترجم: Khaled Ali
المدقّق: Khadra Salem
مرحباً
منذ 7 سنوات،
عندما بدأتُ رحلة التطوّع،
كانت رحلةً مليئةً بالإنجازات والتحديات.
إلّا أنّ الرحلة الحقيقية بدأت منذ 4 سنوات.
تعرفون ما هي؟
هي أن تعمل كجزءٍ من مجموعة،
مع أشخاصٍ آخرين.
بدأتُ العمل مع 20 شخص آخرين،
من أجل تحقيق فكرة.
الفكرة كانت مساعدة الشباب،
على جميع الأصعدة.
رأينا أنّ مجتمعنا بحاجة لذلك.
تحوّلت الفكرة إلى مبادرة.
ثم أصبحت الآن فريقاً.
و مستقبلاً، ستأخذ شكلاً أكبر وستتطور أكثر.
عندما بدأنا، كنا مدركين،
لحجم الفجوة الموجودة عند الشباب،
فقد عايشنا تلك الفجوة.
و كنّا أمام خيارين:
أن نكون مجرّد هواةٍ، يعملون دون تنظيم.
أو أن نشكل فريق عملٍ منظّم،
وفق قواعد معيّنة.
ومنذ 3 سنوات، بدأت فكرة الفريق.
وخلال رحلة مدتها 4 سنوات، أثبتنا للجميع،
أننا لسنا مجرد فريق أو مبادرة،
بل أكثر من ذلك.
والعوامل الرئيسية لذلك هي أربعة عوامل:
العامل الأول، هو التشاركية.
تشاركنا بالأفكار،
و بكل الأعمال التي قمنا بها.
وتشاركنا أيضاً مع عدة جمعيات و قطّاعات،
الخاص منها و العام.
بالإضافة للفرق التطوّعيّة الأخرى،
مما عزّز مفهوم التشاركيّة لدينا.
فأصبحنا نقدّم الفائدة،
لمئات الأشخاص بدلاً من العشرات.
العامل الثاني، هو استثمار الموارد المتاحة.
فقد استفدنا من خبرات الكثير من الأشخاص،
لأنهم آمنوا بفكرتنا وأُعجبوا بعملنا،
و قرّروا أن يدعمونا.
وبالتالي أتاحوا لنا
الموارد المتوفّرة لديهم.
ونحن بدورنا،
استثمرنا هذه الموارد بالشكل الصحيح.
العامل الثالث، هو الاحترافية
فقد حاولنا أن نعمل باحترافية قدر الإمكان.
عندما بدأنا كان لدينا هيكلٌ تنظيميّ.
والذي استغربه بعض الناس،
أن يكون لدى مبادرةٍ صغيرة هيكل تنظيمي.
إلّا أننا فضّلنا العمل وفق هيكل تنظيمي،
ولو كان هيكلاً صغيراً.
الأمر الذي استحسنه شركاؤنا
و متابعينا و حتى المستفيدين من عملنا.
وجدوا فرقاً واضحاً بيننا و بين جهاتٍ أخرى.
حاولنا مساعدة العديد
من الأشخاص و الجهات.
بعض الجهات استفادت من خبراتنا،
و أرادت العمل مثلنا.
و نحن بالمقابل شاركناهم بالموارد،
كما شاركناهم بالخبرات،
لكي يصلوا إلى غاياتهم.
التجربة التي بدأتها أنا،
أصبحت مكونة من 20 شخصاً.
و كلّ شخص منكم يؤمن بفكرة،
يمكن أن يزرعها في 20 شخص آخرين.
تلك التجربة، هي "الريادة المجتمعية".
كيف تكون رائداً في المجتمع،
تفيد مجتمعك و تفيد زملائك،
بشكل إحترافيّ وليس مادّي.
بعد 4 سنوات، وصلنا إلى ما نحن عليه.
الكثير من النّاس آمنوا بنا،
الكثير من الشّركاء ساهموا معنا،
و المستقبل مفتوحٌ أمامنا.
العامل الرابع, أننا قرّرنا أن نكون سنداً.
سنداً لأنفسنا أولاً.
فعندما بدأنا،
كنا ندرّب أنفسنا، وكل شخص في الفريق.
بعد ذلك أصبح كل واحدٍ منا سنداً،
لأصدقائه و زملائه،
حتى لأساتذته، و لأي شخص بحاجة للمساعدة.
بعد 3 سنوات أصبحنا سنداً،
لعدد كبير من الشباب و الشركاء.
تجربتي بدأت كتطوع،
و انتهت بإنجاز كبير مكوّن من 20 شخصاً.
و برأيي، سنتمكن من جعله أكبر مستقبلاً.
لكن يجب ألّا ننظر للمجتمع كمنافس،
لا ننافس الفرق الأخرى،
كما كان الحال من قبل،
بل نعتبرهم شركاء في العمل،
بالتالي سنعمل لمصلحة المجتمع.
و أقول لكم إنّ أيّ إنجاز تطمحون إليه،
ستحققونه، عن طريق،
الإيمان بالفكرة و العمل عليها بشكل صحيح،
مع وجود الشركاء المناسبين.
فريقي المكون من 20 شخصاً،
أصبح كل واحد منهم،
مصدر إلهام لمن حوله في كلّ مكان.
سند أصبح طريقة تفكير، وليس مجرّد فريق.
أعضاء الفريق أشخاص متميّزون،
ولديهم الكثير ليقدّموه.
و أنت أيضاً، لتكون سنداً،
عليك أن تكون متميّزاً في مجالك.
خلال 3 سنوات، حاولنا معرفة حاجيات الشباب،
بالتالي عرفنا ما علينا فعله.
إنّ مشكلة الشباب الرئيسية،
هي عدم وجود دافع يحفّزهم.
يقولون لك: لم نجد عملاً،
لا أحد يريد توظيفنا، نريد السفر.
لكن في الواقع هناك العديد من الفرص،
إذا بحثتم عن الشركات التي تعمل في مجالكم.
عندما عرفنا حاجات الطلاب و الشباب،
قمنا بالعمل على برامج تناسبهم،
و تناسب احتياجاتهم.
و تواصلنا مع الشركات والجامعات،
لكي نحل المشكلة في جميع مراحلها.
الجامعة شاركتنا العمل،
و قامت بتوفير القاعات و الأماكن.
و الطلاب شاركونا آراءهم،
و وضّحوا لنا مشاكلهم.
في النهاية،
كل شخصٍ يمكنه أن يكون سنداً لنفسه،
سنداً لعائلته، سنداً لجامعته.
كلّ شخص حتى أستاذ الجامعة،
و الموظف في شركة،
يمكنه أن يكون سنداً لغيره.
شكراً.
(تصفيق)